вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Ми раді що ви з нами
мільйони людей у Туреччині назавжди
запам'ятають катастрофу яка сталася
Минулого року подію яка безповоротно
змінила їхнє життя рано вранці 6 лютого
сильний землетрус спустошив південну
частину країни сотні тисяч будівель було
пошкоджено або зруйновано багато людей
опинилися під завалами понад 50 000
людей загинуло у цій катастрофі
президент Туреччини реджеп таїп ердоган
швидко пообіцяв фінансову допомогу і
нове житло постраждалим від цієї
катастрофи опоненти критикували його за
те що він використав цю трагедію на свою
користь і для своєї передвиборчої
кампанії тепер рік потому наша
кореспондентка відвідала місто антакя
розташоване в одному з регіонів уражених
землетрусом там вона зустрілася з людьми
які досі живуть серед руїн борючись за
миті
спокою
турецьке місто антакя яке колись було
домівкою для сотень тисяч людей виглядає
як поле руїн і пустерів рік по тому як
його зруйнували потужні
землетруси екскаватори продовжують
розбирати завали багато районів
практично безлюдні непридатні для
життя на околицях зруйнованого рідного
міста енгн ашкар намагається відчуття
нормальності для своєї доньки кавін як і
багато хто тут у зоні землетрусу зараз
вони живуть у контейнерному будиночку
похмурій металевій коробці яку виділив
уряд енгін кавін її мама севаль та її
молодший брат Алі давай трохи
потанцюємо але будь
обережна тут доволі тісно шестирічній
кавін майже не має
дедигратися у їхньої сім'ї є і інші
[музика]
проблеми у нас багато перебоїв із водою
Іноді я буджу дитину о 2і годині ночі
щоб помити
її тому що саме тоді у нас з'являється
вода інфраструктура міста
зруйнована Влада не може з цим впоратись
усе стало дуже
складно енгін і саваль учителі вони
розповідають що колись у них був будинок
стабільний заробіток і плани на
їхня сімя почувалася захищеною та в
безпеці але все раптово змінилося рік
тому рано вранці 6
лютого крізь було дуже
темно я озирнулася і побачила що стіни
тріщать усе падало з
віддусіль Я думала що мені сниться
[музика]
кошмар це був не кошмар а землетрус
силою 8 бала за яким послідував Іще один
потужний поштовх усього через кілька
годин ці землетруси спричинили
безпрецедентні руйнування на південному
сході Туреччини близько 300 000 будинків
зруйновані або стали непридатними для
експлуатації в 11тьх провінціях
рятувальні команди прибули запізно за
офіційними даними загинуло понад 50 000
людей експерти звинувачують неякісне
будівництво і не дбали дотримання норм
безпеки у масштабах катастрофи ніколи в
житті не було так
страшно Я намагався захистити свою
доньку щоб з нею нічого не
сталося вона весь час повторювала мамі
все добре Все буде добре тато нас врятує
він з нами не
плач через рік сотні тисяч людей в цьому
ураженому регіоні живуть у величезних
контейнерних містечках та інших
тимчасових
прихистках попри зимові морози та дощі
чекаючи на відновлення своїх
міст незабаром після цих землетрусів
президент реджеп таїп ердоган дав
сміливі обіцянки Він сказав що половину
зони катастрофи буде відбудовано
протягом одного
року наша мета на першому етапі
завершити будівництво 320 я будівель і
сільських будинків протягом року і
передати їх
власникам але відбудова просувається
набагато повільніше ніж було обіцяно на
цьому будівель майданчику в антакї
Мустафа Арслан і його команда
намагаються встигнути здати перші кілька
тисяч квартир до лютого він хоче
пояснити причини
затримок найбільша зараз проблема - це
дощ у регіоні йдуть дуже сильні дощі але
ми працюємо безперервно Ми хочемо бути
впевненими що люди які пережили
землетрус зможуть заселитися якнайшвидше
антак є місто яке намагається знову
стати на ноги багато власників магазинів
тепер торгують із контейнерів мобільні
телефони одяг солодощі але економіка тут
стоїть на колінах більшість їхніх
колишніх покупців або мертві або
вимушено переселені щоб допомогти своїй
шестирічній донці кавін упоратися зі
страхами і травмами після землетрусів
енгін відвозить її в улюблене
місце Окей повторюйте за
мною
три
чотири балетна школа фатми
сатар деякі з маленьких балерин тут
осиротіли унаслідок цієї
катастрофи викладачка Фатма знає що
переживають діти вона сама втратила
рідних І близьких під
завалами більшість дітей не посміхалися
вони постійно відволікалися вони були
настільки наляканими що не хотіли
розлучатися Зі своїми сім'ями але
поступово ми допомагали їм подолати свої
страхи Ми робили це за допомогою
мистецтва Ми робили це З любов'ю Ми
робили це працюючи разом Ми просто
хочемо щоб до них повернулася частинка
їхнього старого
життя ці уроки танців допомагають і
батькам Для нас це наче перерва ми
можемо нарешті зробити глибокий вдих і
на мить забути про всі наші проблеми Це
приємне відчуття
танцювати веселитися і не думати про
кошмар землетрусів для кавін та інших
дітей це найщасливіші
моменти невеликий тайм-аут від
незвичного нового життя у їхньому
зруйнованому
місті вони королі і королеви моря
кити Хоч вони поширені в океанах
Середземне море також може похвалитися
значною популяцією цих вражаючих
ссавців на жаль їхньому існуванню
загрожує не лише діяльність людини на
морі але й дедалі більше загроз із
суходолу Сабіна аерольді поставила собі
за мету захищати китів і підвищувати
обізнаність про небезпеки з якими вони
стикаються у своєму природному
середовище
існування раннє відправлення з Порту
Санремо
себіна айрольді очолює експедицію вздовж
італійсько-французького узбережжя до
заповідника пилагос домівки для понад 2
ся китів вони під загрозою судноплавство
стало смертельною небезпекою для китів
знову і знову трапляються серйозні
інциденти були випадки коли ніз корабля
зіштовхувався із фінвалом або
кашалотом ті хто стоять біля штурвалу
навіть не помічають цього
Візьміть це фото вантажний Корабель
заходить у гавень ось так І ніхто цього
не
помічає команда щось помітила Сабіна та
її помічник Маріо Припускають що це
дельфіни Вони намагаються підійти
ближче он вони
он Боже мій він
наближається тут близько 15 дельфінів Їм
цікаво Але незабаром вони
відпливають на палубі все записують ці
дані передадуть
університетам їхній човен пливе далі
подалі від узбережжя туди де мають бути
кити у падуанському університеті
професор Сандро мацаріоль намагається
зрозуміти загрози для китів під іншим
кутом зору коли в Італії викидається на
берег мертвий кит він починає своє
розслідування мацаріоль судмедексперт
серед дослідників китів Сьогодні він
досліджує двох дельфінів обидва померли
молодими їх знайшли на пляжі біля
узбережжя Венеції
останніми роками ми виявляємо те чого
раніше не бачили поширення вірусів
бактерій і патогенних мікроорганізмів з
материка зважаючи на те що їх там не має
бути це нас дуже
турбує сильні повені як наприклад в
Емілії романьї минулого літа змивають
патогени з удобрених полів у море ці
патогени із суші становлять серйозну за
для імунної системи морських
ссавців Маріо погляньно сюди Я щось
бачила здається я щось бачила видих і
занурення якщо собіна помітила фінвала
то Приблизно через 10 хвилин Йому
доведеться знову спливти на поверхню щоб
вдихнути скільки вже минуло 9 хвилин
нові
мінути он
[оплески]
він це фінвал майже 20 м
завдовжки це дивовижне відчуття Я ніколи
раніше не бачила кита Це неймовірно
контактувати з твариною яка набагато
більша за тебе на його спинному плавці
Шрам можливо від рибальської ліски або
Корабельного гвинта в іншому тварина
виглядає
здоровою навіть після сотень разів
звісно Спочатку це завжди той самий
великий порив почуттів але потім в мені
прокидається дослідниця Я знаю що мушу
збирати
дані повертаємося до порту Санремо
себіна айрольді хоче якнайшвидше оціни
всі нові дані щоб поділитися ними з
дослідниками з падуанського університету
потім вона знову вирушить захищати китів
Середземного
моря минуло майже два роки як Росія
розпочала повномасштабне вторгнення в
Україну відтоді Європейські країни серед
яких і Франція наклали на Росію жорсткі
санкції ця війна зачепила і російський
цвинтар у паризькому передмісті
санженев'єв дебуа
Росія перестала платити за утримання
могил однак є люди такі як жан-п'єр
ламот і вра оболенський які сповнені
рішучості зберегти цю частину російської
культурної
спадщини у сантдженев'єв дебуа панує
тиша старі могили меланхолійне повітря
Вера оболенськи одна з небагатьох
постійних відвідувачок цього місця їй 73
роки вона нащадниця російських
аристократів які втекли на захід у
1917 році рятуючись від комуністів Вона
відвідує могилу своїх батьків раз на
кілька
тижнів це кладовище не просто не схоже
на інші воно відчувається Як наше бабуся
і дідусь оболенський втекли через
Туреччину та Угорщину Її батьки Серж та
Ірен приїхали до Парижа у 1930 роках тут
вони тількино
познайомилисяце наша сім'я мені тоді
було 10 ми аристократи Я належу до 34го
покоління оболенськи існують щонайменше
з 10 століття ми завжди займали важливі
державні посади і були частиною
аристократії вони не єдині видатні люди
поховані тут жанп'єр ламот експерт з
історії цього
цвинтеря Ходімо Я покажу тобі могилу про
яку ти можливо не знаєш могилу юсупова
який вбив впливового проповідника
Григорія Распутіна він був одружений на
племінниці царя Миколи
iго тут знайшли свій останній спочинок
багато представників колишньої
російської еліти лише відомі постаті
такі як Тарковський знаменитий
кінорежисер високопоставлені військові
художники письменники були тут поховані
близько 150 я росіян емігрували до
Франції в ті
часи після вторгнення Росії в Україну на
цьому цвинтері стало Ще тихі
раніше сюди часто приїжджали російські
туристи А коли нащадків не залишалося
Росія платила за догляд за могилами
тепер цього немає французька асоціація
доглядає за приблизно шістьма сотнями
могил ми несемо моральну
відповідальність без свого спокою
свинтер перестає бути духовним місцем
кожна могила має бути місцем для
молитви серед усіх видатних постатей
одна могила привертає особливу увагу
[музика]
це
нуреєв радянський артист балету і
хореограф Рудольф нуреєв ефектно втік на
захід у
році довгий час я бачив як літня жінка
скрадалася навколо його
могили а потім я дізнався що вона
провела на ній усю ніч Ні я не можу в це
повірити Як ти думаєш ким вона була
костюмеркою старе кладовище сандженевєв
дебуа багато цікавих розповідей і багата
історія Лише кілька місяців минуло
відтоді як азербайджанські військові
почали наступ на людей вірменського
походження що живуть у регіоні нагірного
карабаху незважаючи на те що етнічні
вірмени проживали там протягом
десятиліть Азербайджан відновив контроль
над цією територією наш кореспондент
вирушив до цього регіону який був
повністю спустошений щоб дізнатися про
плани наповнення його новим
життям звивиста дорога до нагірного
карабаху щоб проїхати сюди Нам потрібні
спеціальні дозволи від уряду
Азербайджану які перевіряють на ось
таких контрольно-пропускних
пунктах іноземним зні групам тут не
дозволено вільно пересуватися попереду
їде азербайджанський супроводжуючий але
все добре видно 30 років війни залишили
свій
слід міни та боєприпаси досі вкривають
землю поруч стара
азербайджано-вірменська лінія фронту
Сьогодні джабір самадов його команда
шукають нерозірвані міни це небезпечне
для життя
завдання
так було декілька
смертей солдати та інші
військовослужбовці
також навіть дорога до туалету Має бути
чітко позначена ми запитуємо хто
встановив міни вірменичи
азербайджанці територія яку ми зараз
очищаємо була замінована нашим
ворогом станом на зараз ці території
заміновані тут нас перебиває наш
супровідник його не влаштовує
формулювання
самадова Ми не говоримо вороги ми
говоримо сепаратисти вірмени нам не
вороги ми не бачимо в них
[музика]
ворогів міни були встановлені
вірменськими сепаратистськими силами у
карабасі
[музика]
що ж це змушує мене замислитися чи
почуємо ми тут чесні думки чи тільки те
що нам дасть почути азербайджанський
[музика]
уряд ми знову в
дорозі Нагірний Карабах розташований на
території Азербайджану але історично
його населяли переважно
вірмени у 1990х роках Вірменія взяла
його під військовий контроль і багато
азербайджанців були змушені тікати зараз
ситуація змінилася Азербайджан Багатий
на нафту і газ взяв самопроголошену
республіку воблогу а потім відвоював її
що призвело до переміщення 100 000
вірмен населені пункти перетворилися на
міста примари
є місця які ми навіть не можемо
відвідати поруч з усім цим льні
майданчики Азербайджан будує квартири
для азербайджанців таких як Ісмаїл
сулейманов Він показує нам свою нову
оселю куди переїхали сім'єю кілька
тижнів
тому ось це
Кухня тут ми
їмо Кухня три кімнати ванна
балкон за їхніми словами уряд подарував
цю квартиру родині як компенсацію
подружжя родом звідси але вони були
змушені у 90х роках але Чому вони так
хотіли
Повернутися у Баку у нас було державне
житло у нас там не було справжнього дому
ми завжди говорили що Одного дня ми
повернемося вони обоє з дитинства живуть
як біженці чи задумуються вони часом про
нинішніх вірменських
біженців Ні Чому я повинен про них
думати Я думаю лише про свою країну свою
Батьківщину
Сулейманова не назвеш
співчутливим крім квартири він до речі
отримав роботу водієм вантажівки від
держави розмова з сусідами поза камерою
дає нам іншу картину так квартири чудові
каже Дехто з них але роботи майже
[музика]
немає критичних голосів в Азербайджані
особливо коли йдеться про Нагірний
Карабах небагато але вони уе ж є ми
провели це інтерв'ю без нашого
супроводжуючого наш співрозмовник
виступає в інтернеті проти політики
війни і попросив зберегти його
анонімність за його пости його кілька
разів допитували спецслужби навіть били
Вони сказали Наступного разу ми
приведемо тебе і твою родину І будемо їх
катувати А що мені сказали ми згвалтуємо
твою
матір після війни Азербайджан і Вірменія
обережно рухаються до нормалізації
відносин розмови про обмін полоненими та
мирний договір витають у повітрі але
недовіра все ще відчутна як і страх
перед відновленням
[музика]
насильства А зараз ми перенесемо вас до
Латвії у західній частині цієї країни
знаходиться волость балгали і це місце
пропонує ідеальні умови для одного із
найпопулярніших зимових видів відпочинку
у
Латвії тут ви можете побачити
спорядження необхідне для підготовки до
того що має принести користь вашому
здоров'ю але попереджаємо це не для
слабодухих якщо іделічна краса Північної
Європи здається вам занадто іделічною
пробийте ополонку і пірнайте купання в
крижаній воді фірмовий зимовий вид
спорту в Латвії реально класно Це просто
робить нас
щасливими справді що саме робить цю
крижану авантюру такою
особливою ми поїхали у балгале на заході
Латвії у гості до 33річної сінти дремане
вже три роки вона купається на
відкритому повітрі раз на тиждень
незалежно від того температура вище чи
як Зараз нижче нуля першу потрібно
розчистити ополонку при міну10 за цельсм
во вона знову дуже швидко замерзає і ось
Настав час зануритись у холодну воду
сьогодні папірнати прийшла
84річна бабуся Астра вона справжня
ветеранка
цей екстремальний досвід може тривати до
[музика]
хвилин як взагалі можна витримувати
такий
холод коли ви вперше Заходите в холодну
воду Ви відчуваєте шок
вам важко
дихати тому ваше перше завдання взяти
дихання під
контроль зосередитись глибоко вдихнути і
видихнути і зробити так щоб дихання
стало
рівномірним у південноєвропейців від
такої розваги можуть зацокотіти зуби але
тут на півночі це традиція кажуть що
вікінги практикували крижані копання
понад ся років
тому сьогодні тисячі латвійців ються
взимку прост неба у тому числі у річці
даугава у столиці Ризі лід тут товстий і
об його уламки можна серйозно поранитися
тому чоловіки з асоціації полярні
ведмеді протягом кількох годин
підготовлюють місце купання для
любителів екстремальних
температур це типово Латвійське заняття
адже ми латвійці звикли до суворих ЗИМ і
тому не дуже боїмося
холоду не
во
ретум Ми купаємося в холодній воді і
почуваємося
чудово крижані купання вважаються
корисними для здоров'я коли ви стрибаєте
в холодну воду судини тіла звужуються а
коли виходите вони знову розширюються що
прискорює кровообіг та сприяє зміцненню
імунної системи повідомляється що
любителі крижаних купань застуджуються
рідше ніж люди які приймають гарячий душ
Тім трохи теплої води наприкінці не
зашкодить але сінта дремана каже що ви
обов'язково маєте навчитися крижаному
копанню і хтось повинен надихнути вас на
це я почала з
дитинства я слухала захопливі розповіді
моєї бабусі про те як це чудово скільки
енергії Це дає і яке приємне відчуття
Свободи Ти отримуєш Коли йдеш купатися
взимку це своєрідна
магіясобливо коли нагріється біля каміну
який розпалив її
чоловік їхні діти Емілія рудольфс і
рейніс ще не купаються Цієї зими
натомість вони ходять бо соніш по
снігу Така любов родини до холоду робить
їх сильними особливо зараз у ці
неспокійні
часи ми вчимо наших дітей
насолоджуватися життям тут і зараз
щодня ми вчимо їх користуватися
всімаливо
visur Em vienmr
ldzi особливо не боятися замерзлого
озера де ті любителі зимових купань
можуть чудово розважитися аби тільки лід
залишався достатньо
товстим у мене мурахи від одного лише
погляду на них а на цьому Ми завершуємо
сьогоднішній випуск Європа У фокусі
пам'ятайте ви завжди можете знайти наші
історії та репортажі у соціальних
мережах і з вами була я лісшу Дякуємо за
перегляд до наступної
[музика]
зустрічі